richard branson is planning to fly into
space tomorrow in one of his virgin
galactic vehicles just ahead of jeff
bezos who says he'll go nine days after
that
there are plenty names you know when it
comes to our space program neil
armstrong buzz aldrin
john glenn but there are others you
probably don't including
paul dye the longest serving flight
director in nasa's history
i recently wrote a book on his 30-year
career it's called shuttle houston
my life in the center seat of mission
control he's now retired so free to
speak his mind about the past
and future we met die at his home in
nevada for a fascinating conversation
and a fun flight
paul dye's backyard is unusual
there's no grass or pool but there is
a runway we just go we kind of treat our
airplanes like bicycles you know if you
want to go to the end of the street you
go to the end of the street
this is your garage yeah this is my
other garage in the hangar off dye's
home
there are five experimental planes all
built by
dye himself five and a half you know one
isn't finished
i'd rather fly in a full airplane it's a
bitter to have the plane
sooner or later it'll be flying yeah
on a windy morning outside reno we went
up in
dye's rv8 our flight path took us within
sight of
naval air station fallon home of the
real
top gun we we try and stay out of top
guns air space
probably a good idea yeah though i
briefly took control
took us up a little bit too much there
yeah yeah you know it's a very sensitive
area
severally sensitive very sensitive other
requests were turned down
can i land the plane ah not today
for a number of years dai was editor in
chief of kit planes
magazine where he still contributes but
the most impressive part of his resume
is with
nasa where he worked for more than 30
years
including 20 years as a flight director
longer than
anyone else in history i consider myself
kind of a field general
i really like being in the battle i like
being
in the thick of things and i kind of
recognized early on that
unless i became a politician and ran for
office i wasn't going to be setting
policy i was going to be carrying policy
out
and i was just going to get frustrated
if i moved up higher in the organization
trying to set policy and not being able
to so
i recognized that what i really enjoyed
doing was being in real time operations
and
i tell people do what you enjoy what did
you do nothing i stirred the text
audiences have enjoyed seeing roles like
dyes portrayed on the screen for years
houston we have a problem in 1995 ed
harris played longtime flight director
and nasa legend gene krantz
in apollo 13. we never lost an american
in space we're sure as hell not going to
lose one on my watch
get them away from that booster it's
still armed recently the position of
flight director has been central to the
plot of the apple tv series
for all mankind figure out their status
and where they're headed
on it flight puppy flight dye's book
shuttle houston
details the exhaustive training
necessary to rise to the position
and the monumental work of thousands of
people that went into running the
shuttle program
america's first space shuttle and the
shuttle has cleared the tower
the first u.s shuttle flight was 40
years ago this year
the last was 10 years ago and lift off
the final liftoff of atlantis i
personally think that we could have
continued flying shuttle
for a long time and i think we should
have continued flying shuttle for a long
time because we had things we could do
with it
this may not be the widespread
understanding but space shuttle was
conceived as a way to build and service
a space station
taking care of that station has been
complicated by the shuttle's retirement
the station is being serviced pretty
well these days by a variety of
expendable and slightly reusable
spacecraft but they're smaller
and and i wish we had that capability to
bring large things up and bring large
things back
we don't this is videotape of the
liftgraff this morning of the space
shuttle challenger
while i was with nasa two national
tragedies took place
challenger go with throttle up
challenger exploding after taking off in
1986.
flight director confirms that we are
looking at
checking with the recovery forces to see
what can be done at this point
colombia breaking apart upon re-entry in
2003.
the columbia is lost there are no
survivors
because flight directors work on a
rotation dye was not
involved in coordinating either of those
missions
but the pain remains he is well aware
mortal risks will always be inherent in
space travel
as americans debate where they should
put their focus next
the moon or mars my opinion
with experience is i would like to see
us really focus on the moon so that we
can build
the capability to permanently live on a
planet
i would rather have a major problem
occur two and a half days from home
than eight months from home so i guess
i'm a little bit conservative a little
step by step
in that regard rather than just going
straight to mars which
we really could do but i'd like to see
us have a permanent presence
okay flaps are coming pre-landing
checklist is complete dye
firmly believes heavy investments in
space should continue
both public and private i think
all you have to do is look at what nasa
has contributed in the past and i think
you recognize then how important it is
for the future first
is flat out inspiration holy smokes look
what we can do as a people i mean we've
gone to the moon
we've had people in orbit continuously
we are a space
faring species for over 20 years
but then you also look at the technology
that has come out that we take
completely for granted today the
microelectronics industry
basically grew out of the apollo program
when they needed a very small compact
computer to go to the moon there's two
big technology drivers in history
wars and exploration and i'd a lot
rather spend that money and get the
technology from exploration than wars
sounds like the right idea yeah to me i
asked him if he'd be down for one of the
space tourism flights
really branson's gonna take first and
then and then bezos he said yes if
someone else is paying
keeps coming back to that yeah right he
wouldn't be the oldest i mean wally funk
is headed up who's like that's right
she's what 82 83 80 well whatever
in her 80s she's in her 80s jeff and
looks good
yeah she has goose pimples all the way
here we go again